the experts are now claiming that more
than 400 billion dollars in pandemic
unemployment aid
has been stolen with much of it ending
up in the hands of
surprise foreign crime syndicates
joining me now
republican congressman from utah burgess
owens he's a member of the house and
education and labor committee
and obviously a man who got elected
because we want people in washington who
care about stuff like this
sir we listen to this the government
wants to take more control over our
lives
we trying to be generous getting money
into the hands of people
uh it's the united states government the
best most important country in the world
and somehow 400 billion dollars
ends up in with it with criminal
syndicates in the hands
of the you know the worst of our enemies
uh what do you say to this as a
congressman that this is able to happen
in the 21st century what do you tell the
american people
well let me just say this first time i i
was tempted to stand up and give a
standing ovation for that
monologue but i i i control myself uh
no i i tell you very simply this this is
example what happens we let elitists
take charge it's the same group that is
now paying people to stay home
have small business competing against
the government which they can never win
you go through a litany of things that's
happened in the last six months and
why should we be surprised that they've
wasted or have our money stolen that's
what the left does they have no idea
what is running business
to run anything they reimagine
everything because they've never
imagined anything from
from very beginning so i'm not surprised
and we should not be surprised
and as as it was stated before american
people are waking up
thank goodness this contract is going to
do some great things for us
and 2022 will show that we don't want
this leftist uh
lien in charge that we've been put
through the last six months now you're
relatively new there
do you feel that your your voice
your experience can make a difference is
that do you find that that
panorama there i know it's been unusual
for the last year to say the least
uh but do you feel that you can make a
difference with all of this it's madness
absolutely and i tell you what the
biggest thing that people like myself i
never saw myself as a politician
and what i'm excited about i think
president trump gave us an idea that
non-politicians could make a difference
yes and it says this for
amer all americans out there if you love
our country if you feel confident about
yourself you have a desire to give our
kids a great future
get involved yes whether it be in a
local level this is where we the people
come in and make a difference
and there's no way they can stop us
because that's where the most powerful
powerful
the most powerful three words in history
of mankind is we the people and we'll
get this thing done
bravo it's a this confidence and
optimism it matters because
who we are we know we can do it but it
especially matters when we've got some
trouble sir thank you very much
and thank you for being who you are nice
to see you sir i appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else